what we're going to do in this video is
give ourselves a little bit of a tour of
eukaryotic cells and the first place to
start is just to remind ourselves what
it means for a cell to be eukaryotic
it means that the inside the cell there
are membrane bound organelles now what
does that mean
well you could view it as set as
subcompartments within the cells
membrane
bound
organelles and in this video in
particular we're going to highlight some
of these membrane-bound organelles that
make the cells eukaryotic
so let's just start with some of the
ingredients that we know is true of all
cells so
you'll have your cellular membrane here
a little big so that we have a lot of
space to draw things in
so this is our cellular membrane i'm
doing that little nice shading so you
appreciate that it'll actually be
three-dimensional we see so many slices
of cells that sometimes we we forget
that they are more spherical or that
they have three-dimensional shape to
them they're not all spherical they can
have different shapes
now all cells and there are some
exceptions that we've talked about in
previous videos i should say most cells
will have some genetic information in
them in the form of dna so that is our
dna right over there
now one of the key characteristics of a
eukaryotic cell is that that genetic
information is going to be inside a
membrane-bound organelle and that
membrane-bound organelle or the membrane
that binds or that surrounds the dna
here that is the nuclear membrane
so let me draw the nuclear membrane
right over here
and i'll put some shading in to
appreciate that that also is going to be
in three dimensions around the dna and
so
that is the first membrane-bound
organelle that we're going to discuss
the nucleus
now the nucleus it turns out is
connected to another
membrane-bound organelle and we're going
to study this in future videos but right
here i'm drawing holes or pores in the
nuclear membrane and those pores connect
to something it's a very fancy word
called the endoplasmic reticulum and the
endoplasmic reticulum is essentially
these layers of these
membranes so i'm going to do my best job
at trying to draw an endoplasmic
reticulum imagine extending from these
pores going into a space that has these
really these layered membranes that have
a lot of surface area and i'm not going
to go all the way around this nucleus
but in many cells it will go around all
all the way around the nucleus
and
this right over here and this is just a
rough diagram that is our endoplasmic
endoplasmic
not splasmic endoplasmic
reticulum
which i've mentioned in previous videos
would be an excellent name for a band
and what goes on in the endoplasmic
reticulum is when you are in the process
of taking that genetic information from
dna and as we talk about in other videos
it gets
transcribed into mrna so that mrna is
now containing that information that
mrna will make its way out of that
nuclear membrane through one of these
pores and then make its way to a
ribosome that is attached to the
membrane of the endoplasmic reticulum
and so that's a ribosome there i'm going
to do a bunch of ribosomes and so as
we've talked about in previous videos
the ribosomes are really where you take
that genetic information from that mrna
and then you translate it into a protein
so the ribosomes are the protein
synthesis so let me label that
so
this right over here is a
ribosome
and some ribosomes might be attached to
the endoplasmic reticulum some of them
might just be floating out here in the
cytoplasm so that would be a free
ribosome
free
and even from the point of view of the
endoplasmic reticulum the parts of the
endoplasmic reticulum where you have
ribosomes attached this is known as
rough endoplasmic reticulum
it's the ribosomes that are making them
rough it looks that way in a microscope
so i'll say rough er for endoplasmic
reticulum for short and then you also
have parts of the endoplasmic reticulum
where you do not have ribosomes attached
and because that looks smooth through
our microscope it has been called you
can imagine smooth
endoplasmic
endo endoplasmic
reticulum there are things known as
golgi bodies once again another
fascinating name you got to love these
names in biology that look kind of like
an endoplasmic reticulum but detached
from the nuclear membrane
so let's say something like that that's
my best
drawing there that's a golgi
body
and these are really good at packaging
molecules even proteins that might have
just been produced and packaging them so
that they can be used
outside of the cell for example so and
we'll go into detail in other videos
where a protein might go to the golgi
body get a little envelope around it get
some little processing going on and then
make its way outside of a cell
now another and this is maybe one of the
most famous membrane-bound organelles
outside of the nucleus is what's known
as the powerhouse of the cell and that
is the mitochondria
and so i'll do the of this
in magenta because that's a nice
powerful color
so mitochondria
and i love mitochondria because it's
fascinating how they even came to be
mitochondria actually have their own dna
and all of your mitochondrial dna comes
from your mother and so that's actually
very interesting for tracing maternal
lineage but mitochondria this is where
your i'm going to say let's see what
could see inside of this this is where
your atp is produced this is your
mitochondria it's really the powerhouse
of the cell what's interesting about
mitochondria is evolutionary biologists
believe that
the ancestors of mitochondria because
mitochondria have their own dna they
might have been independent organisms
independent cells and at some point in
our evolutionary past they started
living in symbiosis inside of what will
what would be the ancestors of our cells
and over time they became so codependent
that they started to replicate together
and mitochondria in fact became part of
these eukaryotic cells
now if this eukaryotic cell was a plant
cell or maybe an algae cell you would
have something called chloroplasts there
we don't have them because we don't have
photosynthesis but this is a chloroplast
and if you could see inside you could
see the little thylakoid stacks
right over here you could see the little
thylakoids if you could see inside and
so this right over here is a chloroplast
chlorophyll
and this would be
plants
and algae
animals do not have these and these are
where you have your photosynthesis take
place
photosynthesis
now there's also some other
membrane-bound organelles that are maybe
is less famous than the mitochondria or
the chloroplast or for sure the nucleus
and that might be something like a
vacuole and in plants vacuoles tend to
be very big i could draw it you know
this is three-dimensional so i'll draw
it on top of some of what i've drawn
before
so
if a vacuole right over here this is a
and a plant could be a fairly
significant compartment inside in fact
it can even give structure to the plant
itself because it is so big and it
contains water and enzymes it's viewed
as a kind of a storage compartment but
it can also contain enzymes that help
digest things that help break things
down so that they can be used in some
way so that is a vacuole and they don't
just exist in plants they can also exist
in animal cells but in plant cells they
tend to be they can be very very very
visible
now something that is somewhat related
to some of the function that a vacuole
plays that are most associated with
animal cells but now there's evidence
that they also exist in plant cells is
the idea of a lysosome
so a lysosome right over here
that also is a compartment
and it's going to contain a whole series
of enzymes in it that is useful for
lysing you could say that is useful for
breaking down either waste products as
the cell lives or even foreign
substances that might not be helpful for
the cells so it's going to contain a
bunch of enzymes and it helps break down
things
now i'll leave you there these aren't
all of the structures in eukaryotic
cells but these are enough of the
structures so that you can appreciate
that there are a lot of membrane-bound
organelles in eukaryotic cells and to be
clear even if i were to show all of the
membrane-bound structures that's not all
the complexity of a cell the big thing
to appreciate is cells are incredibly
complex there's all sorts of structures
in here that help transport things and
move things around if you could shrink
yourself down and look inside of a cell
it would look more complex than the most
complex cities there's all sorts of
activities things being moved around
shuttled around the cell itself is
replicating and copying things and so
this is just the beginning we're just
starting to scratch the surface at the
complexity of the most basic unit of
life